now we teamed up with Verizon to bring
you the future of sports
welcome to the Verizon experience at
Super Bowl live I am with Pro Bowler
juju Smith Schuster the Pittsburgh
Steelers the 22 year old star wide
receiver knows how to hustle on and off
the field and he's not slowing down
anytime soon
in fact he's speeding up the future of
sports with Verizon the first to 5g how
will 5g change life for you you know
being able to train with someone you're
not in the same place with I'm the
California and Ben's in Pittsburgh and
we train together so Ben will throw the
ball in Pittsburgh and you'll catch it
in California pretty much it's gonna
change you know the future with sports
so virtual training with quarterback Ben
Roethlisberger sounds pretty cool but
since I'm in the same room with juju I
had to put his skills to the test with
the 5g quarterback challenge we have our
5g first-person goggles and what is
happening is this camera is live
capturing footage it's instantly going
through the network okay so we're gonna
put these on and then we're gonna throw
at those targets yeah we'll see how you
do boom somebody enters a Pro Bowl coach
Tom Lee called me it will be a long time
before juju can live that down and by
the way coach Tomlin I'm not joking
call me if you need help Nancy
[Music]